SIERRA: When we hear about Russia, and we
hear about it pretty often, the news usually
isn't good.
If you were to Google the country on the day
this episode was released, for example, you'd
see a story on the jailing of political dissident
Alexei Navalny and a new deployment of Russian
forces in Syria's civil war.
At this point, we're used to hearing this
kind of stuff when it comes to Russia.
Hacking, military muscle, support for authoritarian
regimes the whole world over.
But what's the story behind that reputation?
Their power isn't derived from their economy
- Russia's GDP is smaller than Italy's, for
example.
So how is it able to exert such a steady influence
in global events?
And why does it pursue the strategies that
it does?
I'm Gabrielle Sierra, and this is Why It Matters.
Today, Russia.
CNN: For the eighth time, Russia has vetoed
a proposed UN Security Council resolution
regarding the horrors and atrocities going
on in Syria over this six-year plus war.”
https://youtu.be/Ae80m8Efk7M?t=89
Indus News: And other news, Russia has reportedly
concluded the delivery of a second S-400 missile
system to China.
Bloomberg: It turns out more US agencies were
targeted by the suspected Russian hack.
The Department of Homeland Security was hit,
and the New York Times says, so are parts
of the Defense Department.
Barack Obama: Russians intended to meddle,
and they meddled.
Mitt Romney: I think that President Putin
represents a real threat to the stability
and peace of the world.
SIERRA: So, Russia is one of those countries
that you hear about a lot in the news, even
if you don't pay much attention to international
relations, right?
So is it really as powerful and influential
a country as it seems to be?
I mean, how powerful is Russia?
STENT: Well, it depends on how you want to
measure power.
My name is Angela Stent.
I am the director of the Center for Eurasian,
Russian, and East European studies at Georgetown
University.
It is the only other nuclear superpower.
The United States and Russia between themselves
possess 90% of the world's nuclear weapons.
So we have to listen to it, we have to pay
attention to it because it can destroy us
many times over.
It has a seat on the United Nations Security
Council.
It inherited that when the Soviet Union collapsed,
the Soviet Union had a seat, Russia now has
that seat, a permanent seat, and that means
it has a veto.
So it can make it very difficult for the United
States and its allies to carry out certain
policies.
And we see that all the time.
It is an energy superpower.
It has the world's possibly largest reserves
of oil and gas; Europe depends a lot on the
energy they produce.
And increasingly, the Chinese are buying their
energy.
DOUGHERTY: If you look at their nuclear weapons,
which is really number one, they can destroy
the United States and probably most of the
world.
So yes, they are powerful.
There's no question.
SIERRA: This is Jill Dougherty.
She served as Moscow Bureau chief during a
three-decade career at CNN.
She currently teaches at Georgetown University
and is a global fellow at the Woodrow Wilson
Center in Washington, DC.
DOUGHERTY: Now, when you go beyond that, there
are many ways that you could count it.
But I would say conventional military; they're
also quite powerful.
If they went into a conflict with NATO, the
United States and NATO together, they would
probably lose, but they are very powerful.
They are developing new weapons.
And they have a sophisticated, educated populace,
and they put as much money as possible into
their military.
SIERRA: Russia is not afraid to use its military
prowess - whether it's in Syria or Ukraine
- and don't worry, we'll get to both of those
later.
But their military investments are also a
significant source of profit.
Russia is the world's second-largest arms
exporter next to the United States.
Its most famous product is the AK 47, designed
in 1949 and still used regularly in conflicts
all over the world.
But Russia also makes highly sophisticated
weapons, like the S-400 anti-aircraft system,
which poses a threat to the most advanced
jets used by the United States and its allies.
Russia's military capability and its enormous
nuclear arsenal form the backbone of its unique
position in the world.
But it's not what we hear about most often
in the news.
SESTANOVICH: There is every reason to think
of Russia as important and powerful.
But the reasons often change.
I'm Steve Sestanovich.
I'm a senior fellow at the Council of Foreign
Relations, working on Russia and Eurasian
Affairs.
I also teach at Columbia University.
I think there are new reasons that people
mention often for why Russia matters.
And in fact, some of the most important ones
that you hear most often these days would
not have been mentioned by anybody ten years
ago.
You'd hear a lot today about Russia's cyber
capabilities, the fact that it can use those
to put American infrastructure at risk or
interfere in elections.
You might also hear that Russia has become
an agitator for populist nationalism, that
it has kind of stoked a backlash against democratic
institutions and liberal internationalist
ideas, particularly in the West.
SIERRA: These are the aspects of Russia we
hear about most often in the news - an ability
to infiltrate and exert influence all over
the world, whether through espionage, hacking,
or disinformation campaigns.
In short, Russia isn't afraid to get its hands
dirty.
Other countries do these things too, but Russia
seems to have a unique willingness to use
every capability at its disposal.
And in order to understand this Russia, you
have to first understand something about the
man who runs the place.
A man whose name is often used as a stand-in
for the country itself.
DOUGHERTY: He believes Russia is a great power.
It was a great power under the czars.
It was a great power under the Soviet Union
when he would argue it has saved the world
from the Nazis.
And he believes that culturally and in every
other way, Russia is a major power, and he
wants to put it back on the stage.
He wants it to be at the table when anything
is being negotiated.
He wants Russia's influence around the world.
He's not dictating, kind of like the United
States, "This is the type of democracy you
should follow," but he does believe that Russia
should have influence.
SIERRA: Vladimir Putin was a KGB officer before
the collapse of the Soviet Union.
This event, and Russia's subsequent economic
chaos, is widely seen as a formative moment
in his life, one that clarified his goal of
restoring Russia's former greatness.
Though some saw his rise as unlikely, he became
Russia's president in 1999 and has led the
country ever since.
STENT: As he became president, he published
something called the millennial statement,
and this is now the year 2000, essentially
saying that he wanted to rebuild a strong
state in Russia.
There'd been terrible economic ravages; really,
there was a crash of the ruble, the currency,
in 1998.
So the country was economically really suffering.
And so I think, you know, his vision at that
point came from his training in the KGB, his
patriotism, one could call it nationalism,
but really wanting to build a strong state
with a strong leader.
And I think that has informed him since then,
and what's so interesting is he's been in
power for twenty years now.
SIERRA: Yeah, I was gonna say you said 2000.
It's 2020!
STENT: Right, it's 2020.
So he's seen Western leaders come and go.
And he knows their weaknesses, their foibles,
and he's an element of continuity there, so
that gives him a great advantage.
SIERRA: So how has Putin been so successful
at playing what you've described as a weak
hand for Russia?
STENT: At the age of 24, he became the judo
champion in Leningrad.
Now, why is it important to emphasize the
judo?
It is because I think the skills that he learned
in judo that even if you are weaker than your
opponent, you can sense their own distraction.
If you're very aware of their own weaknesses,
you can take advantage of them and prevail
over them.
So these judo skills, I think, he's used throughout
his life.
He's been successful because he has been able
to take advantage of opportunities that have
been presented to him by the West.
I would say, you know, after the collapse
of the Soviet Union, the United States and
its allies thought we were going to live in
a much more liberal world.
Communism has gone, and Russia will want to
become like us.
Well, it turned out we got that one wrong.
Because I think what we failed to understand
was that Russians are Russians, and they do
have their own view of the world.
They certainly believe they have a unique
civilization; it's different from that of
the West.
And they don't want to become like the West.
And so we didn't really have a plan.
And Putin had a plan.
I mean, even in 2016, if you think about,
when Russia interfered in the 2016 election,
in terms of social media and in terms of cyber,
we were really asleep at the wheel.
By the time we woke up to what was happening,
it was pretty late in the game.
And so he knows how to do that.
He knows how to do that very well.
Sometimes, of course, he makes mistakes, but
he's really perfected the art of playing this
weak hand well, and also of being able to
act as a spoiler on issues where the United
States and its allies have different interests.
SIERRA: If you want to see an example of Putin's
judo skills, you only need to look at Russia's
cyberattacks and digital disinformation campaigns,
which skillfully exploit weaknesses in one
of the West's biggest strengths - its tech
infrastructure.
DOUGHERTY: Cyber is cheap; this is what we
all know.
You can hire people for very little money
with a big bang.
I mean, the results of all of these operations
are really quite great.
And you don't have to spill blood, and you
don't have to spend money on weapons.
So Russia is definitely using this as much
as it can.
So let's go back to 2016 and what we refer
to as the interference in the American election.
CBSN: Turning out a new report that shows
the massive scope of Russia’s disinformation
campaign during the 2016 presidential election.
PBS Newshour: This is the first glimpse we
got into Russia’s interference in the election.
It’s summer of 2016, and hacked and stolen
emails from the Hillary Clinton campaign and
the Democratic National Committee were publicly
released.
CBSN: Facebook, Google, and Twitter all disclosed
they had found Russian interference on their
sites.
DOUGHERTY: So Russia, at that point, was trying
to influence the election.
As we know from congressional investigations
and U.S. intelligence agencies, they were
trying to damage Hillary Clinton, who they
believed was going to win the election.
By default, they were trying to help Donald
Trump, whom they perceived as a better possibility
for doing the things that President Putin
wanted, like getting rid of sanctions and
maybe improving the relationship.
SIERRA: As we found out in an earlier episode,
there's no way to be sure that Russia changed
the outcome of the 2016 election.
What is certain, according to the consensus
of the U.S. intelligence community, is that
Russia did interfere on a vast scale.
Russia is very good at online disinformation.
But it's also good at outright cyberattacks.
News of the most recent attack broke in December.
And while it's still being investigated, it's
already clear that Russia was able to gain
access to secret information from some of
the U.S. government's most important agencies
and also from hundreds of corporate and private
entities.
GOOD MORNING AMERICA: Sources are telling
ABC News that this bridge went undetected
for six months and that among the agencies
targeted were Commerce, Treasury, State, Homeland
Security, and even NIH.
GOOD MORNING AMERICA: Lawmakers are now comparing
the hack to everything from the virtual invasion
to Pearl Harbor.
DOUGHERTY: That is a very different operation
that was not to sow confusion or intrude in
American elections.
That was really an intelligence gathering
operation, at least as far as we know, in
order to get information.
And the question that we don't know is why
did they want that information?
What kind of information did they want?
And what were they planning on doing with
it?
SIERRA: It seems like there are a variety
of techniques, and organizations, and goals
at work here.
I mean, one simple result of all this is that
it has changed my own perception of the internet
and security.
It's to the point where if Slack goes down
or Google Docs, it can feel very much like,
"Hey, there goes Russia again!"
How alarmed should we be about Russia's cyber
capabilities?
DOUGHERTY: I think we actually should be quite
alarmed because they are very sophisticated
when it comes to this type of thing.
They also are not constrained by the laws
that exist in the United States about the
first amendment and privacy.
Certainly, like in Europe, privacy laws are
even stronger.
It's been described to me by people who really
know this business that they are much more
nimble and willing to take chances, to take
it right up to the edge, and maybe even over.
SIERRA: And going over the edge is something
Russia is willing to do, not just in cyberspace
but in the real world too.
In 2014, Russia shocked the world by invading
and annexing the Ukrainian territory of Crimea.
In addition, Russia also began supporting
Ukrainian separatists in the country's southeast
region.
The ensuing war has killed at least 13,000
people so far and has been described as the
most significant security
SKY NEWS: The Crimea is a sparkling jewel
set enticingly in the Black Sea.
It’s been coveted by many peoples and nations
for over 2000 years of history.
ABC World News: Armored Russian vehicles burst
through the walls of Crimea’s Belbek base
today, firing warning shots and throwing sound
grenades.
U.S. Department of State: Six years ago, Russia
invaded, occupied, and attempted to annex
Ukraine’s Crimean Peninsula.
Today Russia’s occupation of Crimea remains
an affront to the international order.
SESTANOVICH: One of the reasons Russia matters
is that it is a broken up empire.
And the borderlands of Russia, all the territories
that used to be part of the Soviet empire,
now have a kind of undefined relationship
with Russia.
There are a lot of countries there that are
nervous about the prospect that Russia will
try to reassert influence over them, try to,
you know, if not gain overt control, at least
make them a part of its sphere of influence.
So the Russian periphery is a kind of source
of conflict of international instability.
And Ukraine is the most important part of
that because it was the most populous of the
former Soviet states that gained independence
in 1991.
And sometimes that tension had burst into
real conflict, as you had when the President
of Ukraine was overthrown in 2014, and the
Russians responded by seizing Ukrainian territory
and by starting a separatist war in the east
of Ukraine.
I think this has been the deepest crisis that
the Soviet breakup created, but it's not the
only one.
Russia has tensions with almost all of the
former Soviet states.
DOUGHERTY: The reason that it happened was
because Russia wanted it back.
I think President Putin wanted it as a symbol
of his power to reunite Russia and to get
the property that had belonged to Russia before.
It was an extremely popular move in Russia
by President Putin.
I mean, I was there at the time, and there
were little ribbons that people were wearing,
"Yes, Crimea is back."
On my refrigerator, I have a magnet, and it
says in Russian, "Khrushchev gave it up."
Then there's a picture of President Putin
looking like a military guy, and it says,
"And Putin took it back!"
So this was a very popular political move.
So it accomplished what Putin wanted.
But in a broader sense, it was the annexation
of territory, and the West would say illegally,
the first annexation in modern times.
So it broke the rule about taking over the
territory of another country.
And that is why it is such a big deal.
It has set a precedent.
But I think there's a bigger issue here too,
which is that President Putin looks at the
former Soviet Union, which is a very big area,
as kind of his territory.
And Russia is intent on continuing to have
control of that area.
That, I think, is what motivates Putin.
So when you look at Crimea, you can say, "Well,
maybe it was a one-off."
But look at what's happening right now in
Belarus.
Would Russia send troops in?
Would Russia want to take it over now that
it's involved in what really is a rebellion?
They haven't so far, but that is a concern.
SIERRA: I mean, it must be pretty nerve-wracking
if you live in Eastern Europe?
DOUGHERTY: It is!
SIERRA: A majority of Crimeans, many of whom
are ethnically Russian, celebrated the annexation.
The situation in Belarus is quite different.
In August, a democratic uprising seemed poised
to overthrow the country's dictator.
But support from Russia helped him initiate
a crackdown that has so far kept that from
happening.
And Russia's willingness to act daringly to
defend its interests is not limited to its
former Soviet empire.
The best example of this is its involvement
in Syria's civil war, which has been described
as the worst humanitarian crisis of our lifetime,
displacing some 11.5 million people and killing
hundreds of thousands more.
STENT: So in the Soviet days, the Soviet Union
had a close relationship with Syria; it was
quite prominent in the Middle East.
After the Soviet collapse, it withdrew.
It didn't have the wherewithal to do that.
But the relationship with Syria was still
important.
There's been a civil war going on in Syria
for a number of years now, really, since around
2011.
And the leader of Syria, President Assad,
was someone who was, you know, closely allied
with Russia.
But the Russians weren't actually involved
in the conflict.
And then, in 2015, it looked as if his forces
were going to be defeated.
And so Putin came to the United States, he
spoke at the United Nations, he met briefly
with President Obama.
And then, a week or two later, the Russians
started bombing in Syria.
The United States was involved in the Syrian
civil war, and we were supporting the forces
that were against President Assad.
And so the Russians came in on the other side,
and they got involved.
And Russia has stayed there.
And Russia and Iran together have been able
to save President Assad from being defeated.
And as a result of that, Russia has also greatly
increased its footprint in the Middle East.
Unlike the United States, it talks to all
of the different countries there.
It talks to Iran.
It talks to all of the Sunni states, and it's
developed a close relationship with Israel
over the past few years.
So this is an example where, again, it's not
a very expensive intervention in Syria.
There aren't very many Russian ground troops
there, but they have their air force there.
They have a base there.
And they've used this as a springboard to
increase their presence in a number of other
countries really quite successfully.
SIERRA: Russia has a knack for never letting
a crisis go to waste and for making unlikely
partnerships.
After all, there are not many countries that
can maintain fruitful relations with Iran
and Israel at the same time.
STENT: Many other countries in the rest of
the world, such as India, Brazil, obviously,
China, regard Russia as a large autocratic
country with which they can do business.
And so Russia's relationship with the West
is very fraught: with the United States, with
the countries of Europe.
But much of the rest of the world does not
have a view of Russia that is malign and thinks,
again, that it's a large country with whom
they can do business.
And I think, sometimes in the United States,
we maybe don't understand that well enough.
SIERRA: Still, no matter how well Russia plays
its weak hand, the point remains that that
hand is weak.
Currently, Russia is facing a number of obstacles
that will affect what the country looks like
in the future and its role on the global stage.
STENT: One of the real challenges that Russia
faces is it has a declining population.
It's demographically really quite challenged.
And it's really been impossible for the Russian
government to persuade people that they should
have a whole lot more children.
But also the other important thing to know
is that they have this unusually high mortality
rate for young men.
And so that particularly affects, for instance,
the military.
SIERRA: In 2019, the percentage of Russian
youth that said they wish to leave the country
reached a ten-year high.
So what does this mean for the future of the
country?
And also, why would that be happening?
SESTANOVICH: Well, the Russian economy has
had a bad decade.
The first decade of Putin's rule was pretty
good.
You had household income going up by multiples.
And that was a big source of Putin's legitimacy
and reputation in Russian domestic politics.
Since the global financial crisis, the Russian
economy has grown at barely 1 percent a year.
And household income has declined several
years in a row.
When that happens, talented Russian young
people, particularly with a good education
or foreign language skills, say, I'm out of
here, if I can find a way to get myself to
Western Europe, or the United States, or the
Middle East.
They tend to look for those opportunities.
As long as Russia continues in a kind of economic
decline, that sort of loss of morale will
be a national problem.
And it's one thing that Putin and his associates
are very aware of.
They keep trying to come up with plans to
turn the population decline around, to reinvigorate
economic growth, but so far, for most of the
past decade, they haven't succeeded.
They have for some time thought of themselves
as, you know, a civilization in decline.
And this too is part of the Soviet act aftershock.
SIERRA: These factors signal trouble ahead
for Russia - but that trouble does not guarantee
a waning of Russia's willingness to act.
In fact, many observers feel that it is precisely
because of these factors - declining population,
a troubled economy - that Russia feels it
must resort to unconventional strategies in
order to exert influence and to undermine
those nations that seem to be leaving it behind.
SIERRA: So, what do you imagine Putin might
have been feeling as he watched the chaos
in Washington, DC on January 6?
SESTANOVICH: Well, you know, Putin has some
very mixed reactions to this.
On the one hand, he has said, liberal democracy,
liberal ideas, the West's sense of superiority-
we challenge all of that.
The conceptions that the West has had about
how to run a country are outdated.
On the other hand, he had hoped that Donald
Trump would be a pal, would be a kindred spirit.
And for him to see Trump hustled out of the
office means the end of a moment in which
you could have had a kind of similar nationalism
that he hoped would be compatible, dominating
in both Russia and the United States.
There's one other element of what happened.
Putin is always unnerved by popular uprisings.
He really hates them because it shows there's
a kind of autonomy to the popular will.
This isn't exactly his idea of how things
should operate.
And he doesn't also like the idea that real
democratic constitutionalism and the rule
of law matter.
So in Washington, when the Congress was meeting
to certify a democratic election, it was doing
something that Putin is uncomfortable with.
And when all of these thugs were storming
the Capitol and breaking windows, they were
also doing something that Putin was uncomfortable
with.
So while he likes the specter of American
weakness, he actually doesn't want people
to unpack any of these events and think too
hard about how they might be exported to Russia.
SIERRA: Putin's fear of an uprising has been
made clear by his ruthless treatment of political
opposition.
Take the case of Alexei Navalny, Russia's
most prominent opposition figure.
In August 2020, Navalny was poisoned with
a Novichok nerve agent, a lethal and rare
substance that has been used to poison other
Russian opposition figures.
He was evacuated to Germany and put in an
induced coma, narrowly surviving the attack.
Following our interviews for this episode,
Navalny made the extraordinary decision to
return to Russia, where he was promptly arrested.
Still, he was able to release a video message
calling for mass protests in Russia, saying,
"there's nothing these thieves in their bunkers
fear more than people on the streets."
SIERRA: So how can the United States find
a way of creating a more stable and effective
relationship with Putin's Russia?
STENT: So I think that first of all, it's
important to know that the Russian constitution
was changed this year, and Putin could now
be in power till 2036.
So that will be a bit longer than Stalin was,
quite a lot longer than Stalin.
So the first thing we have to do is we have
to identify what are the issues on which we
have common interests with Russia and where
we can work with them.
And I think the most important one is arms
control.
I said at the beginning, we are the two nuclear
superpowers, we have an arms control agreement
that regulates our strategic nuclear weapons,
the big ones, and that expires on February
5, 2021.
And it's hoped that the new Biden administration,
and they said they want to do it, can extend
this agreement for five years with the Russians.
The Senate doesn't have to vote on it, if
not a word of the language is changed in the
treaty.
And I think that's an important area where
we have to work with Russia.
Now, they're developing weapon systems that
we don't like, and we're developing weapon
systems they don't like.
But the worst thing would be if we had no
arms control agreement with them and we just
have an out and out arms race.
It's very expensive.
It makes the world more dangerous.
And it encourages other countries to acquire
nuclear weapons, what we call nuclear proliferation.
DOUGHERTY: Russia, I think, affects our lives
in many different ways.
I don't think Russia is intent on blowing
us up, but it could.
It could literally destroy the United States
and the world.
So we should be concerned about nuclear weapons.
We should be concerned about some types of
controls on nuclear weapons.
The United States and Russia are the two countries
that have the most nuclear weapons, and they
are an example to the rest of the world.
So that other countries, such as Pakistan,
India, and many others, look to the United
States and Russia and say, "If you guys can't
come to an agreement on nuclear weapons, why
should we?
Maybe we ought to build up our weapons because
now it's a much more unstable place."
STENT: Another area going forward, since the
Biden administration says it will recommit
itself to fighting climate change and rejoining
the Paris agreements, the Russians used to
be very skeptical about climate change.
And Putin a few years ago said there's nothing
wrong if it gets a little warmer in Russia.
But recently, he's actually singing a different
tune.
He's saying he takes this very seriously.
Russia is already suffering from some of the
impact of climate change.
So going forward, it's possible that that's
an area which isn't too politicized but where
we can work with the Russians.
SESTANOVICH: Russia can be an important player
on the whole set of climate issues partly
because it is greatly affected by the question
of whether or not the world makes a transition
to a post-carbon economy.
The Russian economy is still very dependent
on oil and gas production and exports.
They also are rather uniquely situated to
benefit from changes in climate that make
other countries wonder whether they're as
ready to bear a lot of the burden of the transition
to a different economy, a different set of
post-carbon regulations.
STENT: There are areas where we can work with
them.
But the areas where it's very difficult to
work with them and where we have to be very
realistic are, for instance, anything to do
with their neighborhood.
I think you have to accept that our relationship,
at best, is one of competition and cooperation.
I think that the challenge now really is just
to get back to a more normal relationship.
In the past four years, a lot of the channels
of communication between the United States
and Russia atrophied, particularly those in
the State Department.
I think some of those can be revived.
And that at least there can be this normal
level of communication.
And really not to forget the Russian people
and to keep reaching out to them because the
government doesn't speak for all of the people.
SESTANOVICH: The overused quote about Russia
is that it's never as strong or as weak as
it seems.
But it's always pretty strong.
And still, the reasons that it's strong or
also weak change.
If the Biden administration asks, How much
does Russia matter?
It will have to review all of the issues that
we've been talking about, from nuclear weapons
to climate change, to imperial upheaval.
But one possibility that they'll consider
is that actually, Russia matters a little
bit less than it used to.
They may decide that a lot of these issues
where Russia matters don't actually lead to
the need to cooperate with Russia.
One of the things that Putin probably fears
as much as anything else is being downgraded
in the policy calibrations of Western countries,
the idea that Russia, as much as it matters,
may not matter as much as it did.
DOUGHERTY: It's a smart country.
They have a lot of really educated young people.
Many of them, I think, are patriotic, and
they want Russia to improve.
I do think that if we can understand that
there are ways of working with even the next
generation, that it's important, that there
are problems that go way beyond the political
problems we're looking at right now.
And if we look at Russia as simply an enemy,
we are going to shoot ourselves in the foot.
The best way to deal with these countries,
sometimes I believe, being a former exchange
student in Russia myself, is to bring them
to the United States and send Americans there.
I'll end on this.
Russia has a very powerful culture.
It always has.
Their culture can enrich ours, and ours already
is enriching theirs on many different levels.
I think it's important for Americans to take
them seriously, and not to demonize them,
and not to sell ourselves short by misinterpreting
what they're doing.
SIERRA: In this show, we focus on serious
foreign policy issues because, well, they
matter, and they affect all of our lives.
But sometimes, a nation's people can get lost
in a discussion of their government's policies.
The Russia we hear about in the news can seem
scary - an authoritarian country capable of
carrying out assassinations, annexations,
election hacks, and massive cyberattacks with
seeming impunity.
It's terrifying to remember the scale of Russia's
nuclear arsenal, and our own, as treaty after
treaty lapses.
That is the Russia that is so often used synonymously
with Putin's name.
But there is another Russia, the Russia of
Tolstoy, Dostoevsky, Gogol, and Chekhov.
The Russia of Tchaikovsky, Rachmaninoff, and
Shostakovich.
A long list of mathematicians and scientists
of towering accomplishment.
These are treasures that belong to the world,
and they signify Russia's place in it.
These, too, are reasons that Russia will always
matter.
So, in this spirit, we thought we'd ask our
incredible research consultant Elena Tchanikova
to read us out in her mother tongue.
See you next time, everyone!
TCHAINIKOVA: For resources used in this episode
and more information, visit CFR.org/Whyitmatters
and take a look at the show notes.
Have a question or some feedback?
Feel like saying hey?
Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio.
And, please please, if you are a fan of the
show, show some love!
Give us five stars and leave a review on Apple
Podcasts.
It means so much to us, and it helps us get
noticed.
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations.
The show is created and produced by Jeremy
Sherlick, Asher Ross, and Gabrielle Sierra.
Our sound designer is Markus Zakaria.
Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor, and
Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Original music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
Additional research and extra help were provided
by me, Elena Tchainikova.
Special thanks go to Richard Haass and Jeff
Reinke.
For Why It Matters this is Elena Tchanikova
signing off.
See you soon!